like for instance how do you think
George would do against
Hamza
how do you think he would do how do you
think you would do against you think you
would just mop the floor with Muhammad
those guys rank three and four
you know
you don't you tell me Gilbert Burns
isn't more round more well-rounded than
a lot of guys that GSB fought
name a guy in the top six that's not
more well-rounded than Matt Hughes or
Josh Koscheck
this isn't a hard debate right through
the city like British
[Music]
what's up fam Monday morning welcome
March 27th
spring break for most the kiddos out
there the kids are on break which is a
nightmare for the parents if you're not
going on vacation you're trapped in the
house with those demons for the next
week or so so shout out to all the
parents out there man you got to figure
out what to do with the kiddos I dropped
my kid off at a soccer camp this morning
it was windy I don't
see how they're going to play soccer but
not my problem that's on the coach even
the goals were like blown over he's like
yeah we'll figure it out like have fun
man I'll be back at two you know so
shout out to the parents out there
dealing with spring break right now our
breaks are different aren't they uh
fresh off the plane from Tacoma shout
out to Tacoma
for whatever reason it makes no sense
when you look at analytics because the
way they book touring a lot of times I
mean obviously want to do new markets
but a lot of times if you're doing like
a theater or a big venue they'll do it
based off you're following on Instagram
on social media in general or on YouTube
in the breakdown by City
and for whatever reason the Pacific
Northwest is not that big when it comes
to social media for me breakdown or
YouTube but I sell more tickets in the
Pacific Northwest more than anywhere
else
always since I've been doing County for
eight years I always sell the most
tickets up there for whatever reason I
don't know if it's my love for serial
killers because there's a ton of them
that are from those areas and I actually
walked to Ted Bundy's house
that's me man that's me
this
so that's Ted Bunny's childhood home
which is weird uh that guy put uh I
thought that was the home you bought for
your mom before I read the comment
can you imagine honestly that when I
first saw this picture too I thought
this would be the mother's home I didn't
realize I didn't even think about that
can you imagine like here's your house
it's this little old town yeah so can we
talk about real quick though you
actually bought your freaking
mother-in-law a house that is so
freaking cool dude thanks bro so [__]
cool
thanks man it's amazing yeah
yeah want to play this uh what the field
using a Spanish there
let's see the translation
huh
uh whatever you're doing with an
entertainment podcasting YouTuber
regular gig whatever it is
because kids are playing hide and go
seek the girls always buy your pants a
house well today all that hard work all
those tour dates all that stuff it's
information
I'm buying my mother-in-law house she's
the best grandma in the world she has no
idea this is happening she's going to
pull up the house and give her the keys
so I want to thank the fans out there
for making this possible buying every
single ticket to all those crazy cities
I was in to the haters do you motivate
me more than you know but I love you
guys and what's up guys today
she had no clue I didn't think about
this but she doesn't like the house
yeah she's never seen it well she was
like wait what
I don't realize how many people in the
back feel me mama
she's a thick girl shirt on
mama
[Music]
I love you so much
let's get for being the best grandma
the key was kind of old too it had like
the colored ring on it
look at him
welcome home yeah that's so sweet dude
yeah man that's a big one off The Bucket
List yeah she was happy never owned a
home before man so it's a big deal
big deal man yeah uh yeah that was a big
deal for your boy but shout out to
everyone else for uh all the fans out
there man literally it was a gold mine
probably my kids were born because
they're such she's such a good grandma
and uh my father-in-law Steve he's a
monster too so whatever you know my
schedule's busy man so but
whenever I'm on the road or anything
they're always always at the house
they're always there making sure the
kids are good make sure you know Steve's
a cop so you know security like they're
always always out I don't have to ask
them they've always been like that since
day one you know I was like I keep these
people close man they're the best so
that was my way to give back and even
that's not enough but the house I posted
uh of Ted Bundy is not the house that I
bought them
I didn't buy my house in Tacoma you put
it so close together though
it makes sense when I'd be like wait
hold up that's the house
but you gotta read the caption took a
little morning stroll to Ted buddy's
house there in Tacoma it's like the
downtown Tacoma
there's not a ton going on there there's
a lot of things shut down I think maybe
the pandemic got them stuff like that
like there's there's a lot of that stuff
going on there so it's kind of dead so I
would just watch you know it's just me
and Jay so I just stroll around
everywhere like I I got my 10 000 steps
in by 11 A.M every morning like I was
just strolling around and I found this
site shot to the site I Gotta Give the
site a shout out and then we'll get into
the fighting but
um the site is called
oddstops.com and like whatever murder
serial killer house you're looking for
look the bridge where David Berkowitz
was stabbed you're too into this dude
yeah oh yeah oh dude I didn't I didn't
even share most of the stuff uh you know
like
the Green River Killers it from out
there and the Green River is a river
that was in uh Tacoma like Ted Bundy's
so he grew the house that I took a
picture of that's the house he grew up
in as a kid and then they moved not far
from there uh his parents bought a house
where they eventually died and uh he
stayed there I walked to his high school
uh his college Puget Sound and then we
drove to Seattle I looked up all the
things there I don't know something to
do I guess it's fascinating to me it's
so weird and creepy that place is
definitely haunted but shout out to
Tacoma man big shout out to Tacoma great
freaking comedy venue that Tacoma Comedy
Club my openers were so [__] good man
the comedy out there is booming openers
were great the host in the future both
great man
both grass probably give their names out
huh yeah I was gonna look for it real
quick uh I didn't post anything about
them but
um their names are Adam tiller was the
feature
Adam tiller is a guy
he um his dad went to Harvard and MIT
his dad's Like This brilliant like
brilliant dude
um and then he you know his son's a
comic and so he's this monster out there
just he opened up I think he opened up
for uh a bunch of people Doug Stanhope
uh Whitney like he he's the one
everybody uses but Adam tiller's a
monster and then the the host was a guy
named Charles Hall remind me a lot of uh
Chappelle Lacy he's from Georgia though
he lives in Tacoma now but they're both
great really really good man you never
know what you can get sometimes we don't
bring your own people it's a real crap
shoot sometimes you get some people that
just you know
it happens but let's get into the fight
I was able what's dope about this is
this fight card the ESPN uh Fight Night
in uh San Antonio started I was about I
was able to watch pretty much the entire
card the main event uh
trying to think I probably got on stage
around the third round
yeah third or fourth round so I saw the
majority of it uh listen you know Corey
sanhagen basically came up with the kid
he walked in the gym I've told the story
a million times when he's 15 or 16 years
old he trains with my former you know
one of my closest friends and uh my
coach uh Christian Allen so I'm very
close to Corey sandhagen that whole team
there then Marlon uh Cheeto Vera is my
boy love Marlon so I didn't give a pick
for this fight
um it went how I thought it was gonna go
I thought if Cheeto was gonna win
and I have text uh with Tom who's our
booking agent who's super into MMA he
goes uh prediction between you and I I
said Corey's going to get up big time
because Marlon and this is you know well
documented just what it is with Cheeto
he's a very slow slow starter very slow
starter so of course you can get up
probably at least three rounds before
Marlon gets going but it's gonna be too
late so Marlon has to bank on Corey
slowing down and clipping him in order
to win because this goes to the judge's
scorecards it's going to be a freaking
Clean Sweep it's not going to be good
for Cheeto Chino might get one round but
in general unless he finishing with TKO
he's not going to submit Corey he's
giving some trouble there let's take a
little break before we can jump right
back into the fight game whether you're
new to cannabis or an old bro like some
of my friends out there there's no
denying that many of the products on the
market seem iffy at best you don't know
if you can trust them and all you want
to do is relax all right you don't want
to get all crazy all right so mood my
friends that mood puts an end to the
guessing games it's 100 federally legal
Delta 8 and Delta 9 THC and you can have
ship straight to your freaking door no
doctors no waiting just affordable great
THC products and it's legal for limit
time mood has given you guys free Delta
9 gummies and 20 off your first order
visit
hellomood.com use code shop s-c-h-aub
all right mood offers federally legal
forms of THC extracted from hemp plants
all our products are regularly
third-party tested and Drug Enforcement
Agency registered Labs Source from small
family farms and grown organically
something for every mood what are you
looking for man energize creative Focus
relaxed we got you covered ready for a
good time without the guesswork order
your THC products from mood today and
for twins off your first order and free
gummies go to Hello
h-e-l-l-o-mood.com and use promo code
shop that's hello
m-o-o-d.com promo code shop for twin
soft your order in free gummies spring
has sprung and our friends at manscape
the leaders and blow the waist grooming
have the best tools for some spring
cleaning in your pants trust me your
confidence will be blooming like the
flowers look your best this spring and
join the
over 8 million due to trust manscape use
code shop 20 get twins off and free
shipping at manscape.com manscapes are
here to change the way all the fellows
can take care of ourselves and groom
with the performance package 4.0 you get
the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer the weed
whacker air nose hair trimmer crop
preserver Baldur crop reviver toner
performance boxers and a travel travel
bag you're ready to go man always use
the right tools for the job and head to
their website and check out all their
tools to help you upgrade your hygiene
routine save twin soft and free shipping
with code shop20 at manscape.com that's
20 and free shipping with coach shop20
at manscape.com your balls will thank
you oh man big shout out to my boys at
happy hippo that's right happyhippo.com
they're celebrating 10 years in the game
10 years of supplying the best
pure Kratom on the planet Earth that's
right it's their 10-year anniversary and
they're not just doing any normal sale
they're giving you 30 percent off site
wide 30 percent off everything at happy
hippo go to happyhippo.com promo code is
thick23 and you save 30 off I use the
shots they get the great uh butterscotch
shots or the Apple Shots they got pills
they got powders they got gummies listen
you're not gonna gut all jazzed up like
you would with some other drinks or
stuff like that you get a nice warm
balance good mood feeling all right
their Kratom is a Hidden Gem and right
now if you haven't tried it do this you
get 30 off you have nothing to lose it's
their 10 year anniversary go to
happyhippo.com promo code is thick with
three C's 23 you save 30 off the entire
site you're welcome happyhippo.com promo
code thick23
it's kind of what you saw you know the
the fact that was a split decision so
Chrisley saw the Amato and Joel Ojeda
Ojeda is the one that gave the weird ass
thing and there's a background with him
as well he's not like a a seasoned ref
this is like his fourth ever UFC event
he shouldn't be allowed exactly because
it's a huge event it's the main event
yeah exactly that guy should never work
again I mean split this yeah or get more
training in the you know the original
scenes yeah doing the regional yeah then
come to you he should not be he should
not have scored that was so crazy that
was insane of two of the best
to the best Banning weights on the
[__] planet 135 he should not be
anywhere close to that kid everyone
agrees with you all the fighters he's
lucky even gets a subscription to the
ESPN fight pass at this point he I mean
he needs to do some [__] all this
crazy work that was a clean distance you
could
you could maybe give Cheeto the third
round
that's what uh Chris Lee did but that
was it that it for reals and that's it I
mean he's I think part of the thing too
is cheeto's such a fan favorite that
fifth round one kind of started going
like but just because you start to get
going doesn't mean you're winning the
round just because you love the fighter
it doesn't mean he's winning the round
to give him the third fourth and fifth
you should never work again at least for
a hot second go back to the regional
circuit yeah you're way off dude
but thank God because when they said by
Split Decision I'm like what the [__] is
this is going on I'm sure everyone felt
that way yeah and Corey San Diego looked
fantastic oh my God he looks good good
good he looked really really good I just
think they're on two different paths you
know with Corey obviously
um you know he had the hiccup against TJ
a lot of people think he beat TJ
um I can see the argument I thought TJ
did enough but I get the argument there
and then uh you know then he beat what
uh sat on how do you say his name yeah
he beat him TKO cut yep there's no punk
um so I I just think for Corey and
Cheeto it's the worst matchup possible
for Cheeto unless he was going to catch
him but Corey's a very cerebral fighter
he's just too Multiverse he can stand
Orthodox South Paul kicks submissions
his jab his head movement like there was
a lot for Cheeto to
take take in there and you know when
you're a slow starter you just round up
around you just put it Bank in bank it
Bank it and then also not to mention the
takedowns which I don't think Cheeto was
banking on but the takedown's really
[__] him over too he's wearing them
out I mean look at that dude significant
strikes 128 to 58.
not absolutely not
um yeah the more light kicks for sure
and then uh you know takedowns you know
so it was a bit of a problem for for
Cheeto man yeah takedown's three you
know three big takedowns
um a really really tough fight for
Cheeto I saw Chito called out uh Peter
yawn I like that for him that's another
one Peter Young comes out you know he
peteron downloads your data and then
takes over but you know even in the last
fight uh that he had
um you know
he's still not as slow as Cheeto like I
would still consider petiano a faster
started Cheetos the slowest I've ever
seen and his coach I have to say around
like what are we what's wrong with you
like what's going on there's something I
need to know like what's wrong with you
you know Corey saying called out marab I
thought the move was to call out uh
sugar Shawn because sugar Shawn Corey is
a fantastic fight because marab sugar
could it be a worse matchup possible for
sugar and we want sugar to get to that
title shot right if you're a sugar fan
sugar Cory that's the fight that's the
most entertaining fight as a if if
you're a purist you want Corey versus
[__] that's the fight I think the UFC
is a new Corey versus sugar
it's more fun it's it's again I still
think sugar would be an underdog in that
fight it's a winnable fight for Suga
definitely not neat there's no easy
fights for children anymore that's not
happening PG on was not an easy fight he
passed that test thank God but now you
know I don't think shout out to Corey
sandagen that's what kind of savage he
is for calling um Rob out because the
rest of the vision is like uh-uh if
you're a manager like no no no no no
we'll take anybody but that you know so
um you know I don't think Rob's gonna
sit around either so Rob Corey sandhagen
makes sense but if I'm the UFC uh I just
have Rob wait for the title shot you
know and force the hand if Al Jermaine
were to beat uh Henry cejudo you just
force that hand build the hype up there
but marob's gonna be chilling for a
little bit
because I bet they do Cory versus sugar
that's the fight that'd be super fun for
sure that's the fight yeah but Murad was
down he said let's hell yeah he's down
yeah
and stylistically I would say I mean
sahudo would be a tough matchup from
Murad but out you know in Al jermain's
interesting to think about but course
ending and how dangerous he is on the
ground could be fun against moram and
his cardio you know yeah
the bantamweight my God is it stacked
dude Holly Holm looked fantastic
absolutely fantastic
a lot of people think uh KGB Andrea Lee
uh was Rob but you know Macy Barber did
her thing also those judges what do you
expect man that one judge was a complete
[__]
but yeah it was a great fight it's just
Cheeto just kind of I think it's a a
combination I'll have to talk to him
because this combination I think of his
slow start and he just seemed a little
off a little slower than usual it didn't
seem like the normal Killer Instinct
Cheeto you know horrible matchup for for
Cheeto you know I didn't want to get
into it on Monday's show but
stylistically there could be a horse
matchup for Cheeto yeah because thing
about Cheeto was down on the cards
against
um
and Donald Cruz you know
Corey is a 2.0 version of Dominic Cruz
and he's in his prime so if you look at
Dom's fight Dom had a lot of success
against Cheeto too he was caught with
that head kick so if you just look at
that and you think of Corey
it's a tough [__] fight for him he
can get down the cards you have to pray
for that home run shot at this level
that's tough man very tough
so this is a cheat order statement
afterwards and then he did mention also
that he just couldn't get he just
couldn't start
yeah she's had an off night it happens
man yeah it happens with football
players basketball players UFC fighters
it's happened to me it's just for
whatever reason it's just that I don't
know I just think think about it but
it's no different than whatever place
where you're listening is right about
work like some days you just don't feel
like doing it there's no difference in
professional sports hate to tell you
some days your favorite basketball
player was LeBron James gets the arena
he's like oh I don't feel like doing
this he's just off and it's up even if
you're like I'll it'll get going once
I'm in there it just does it just not
clicking for you sometimes it happens to
UFC fighters during their biggest time
their biggest moments it sucks yeah I
got fights only oh if we could just do
this any other day I'd beat this guy you
know yeah that's how you feel like ah
man if we just delay this like a day of
you not feel like getting punched in the
face today
I wonder if it's because of um I don't
know if this influences it that much but
having an audience an audience around
something that you're doing to you know
a competition even if it's singing or if
it's like yeah whatever just having an
audience there and you're not you're not
like in the mood to do it there's just
something going on maybe it's something
in your life you wake up that you know
how it is so someday some days you feel
good some days you don't mentally you're
just like I don't feel like doing this
it happens with the professional
athletes
you know you don't have you felt that in
training though ever oh expiring well
okay all the time yeah you're like God I
don't want to do this today you're
driving then you gotta get going
um
the only difference is in fighting is
you're not just missing a missing a shot
or the guy's Blowing by you and you know
catching a touchdown you're getting
socked in the [__] face yeah it's a
tough gig in front of a [__] ton of
people yeah it's embarrassing yeah it's
a real bummer
but that's what Cheeto said he said fell
short today got zero excuses just
remember something I won't stop just
wasn't his day no if if they do give him
Peter Yani beats him he's right back in
the mix yeah and you realize Cheeto he's
on this uh surgeons like uh it happens
with certain guys who've been around for
a while where for whatever really takes
a fan base to jump on board it just
takes a little and then they become like
these Legends and no matter even if they
lose we're gonna pay to see him she just
got into that Diaz bro Moz Vidal
category cowboy Cerrone we're like I
don't give a [__] feelings yeah he got
from the crowd was insane yeah
yes he just he became one of those kind
of it's almost like you're this urban
legend you know people don't care
yeah cheetah's one of those guys it's
very rare you can't there's no you know
there's no marketing agency getting
hired to say hey how can we become like
a Mazda doll like a Diaz bro it's just
it just happens and it happens to very
few people you're more likely become a
world champ to become you know one of
those Street Legends like these guys
uh here's a quick one we all know this
already but he's your buddy he's been on
fighting pan before Donald Cerrone he's
actually now inducted into the Hall of
Fame I think it's in July yeah July and
they surprised him right yeah with his
kids and everything I love how they do
that too they don't tell them apparently
don't tell them as far as I know but so
they just see this video highlight and
they're like what the Yeah and then boom
the Jazz Pulver one was even more I know
that the Jazz father one maybe that one
got me
um the cowboy one was great though yeah
boy does he deserve it for sure all the
fighters are like had his back too like
oh everyone yeah everybody
so that was cool to see
um all right so this is
a little bit of a controversial one
Joe Rogan when he had I believe when he
had Luke Combs on his podcast he
mentioned how Jorge Mazda and a lot of
the welterweights in this period of time
right would beat GSP but he mentioned
specifically mozvidol apparently
um
I he's so his statement's partly true so
the UFC is so new that Fighters that are
starting you know that are in Dana White
Contender series certain Fighters
they're training in MMA specifically in
their [__] talented men when GSP was
fighting he's fighting very
one-dimensional Fighters and there's a
way to expose those guys and it's not
just gsp's fault but Rogan's right where
because the Sport's so new like if you
took um Dak Prescott who's good Prescott
that's good that's good if you toss them
back in the 60s he's the best to ever do
it it's just the type of change like you
would take Patrick Mahomes and put them
in the 50s he's throwing 700 yards a
game he's got it's just the game evolves
the science evolves the fighters evolve
they're better athletes GSP wasn't
fighting the same athletes that the guys
are today we're broken I think I don't
say hot one I bet he doesn't give a
flying [__] but where these MMA Outlets
are like oh you believe this yeah okay
but where I think Rogan if he could redo
this uh line of thinking it's the
fighters today are better and GSP wasn't
fighting against competition but but
maswood all has been doing it just as
long as GSP
ah I think might as well started maybe a
year after
as far as like straight up Pro fighting
yeah like might as well even I think
started when he's 15 in the backyard but
that's different but as far as like
their careers look up when Maslow first
started
pro boxing first so you know so let's
say starting 2003 2003 yeah so now I'm
bringing up GSB
this is where it wrote like his point is
correct but Mazda was a bad example
like if you have said that about you
know like an Izzy or uh
oh so two on two like I said he started
yeah so rough they kind of started the
same time so that's where people you
know it's Rogan so obviously it's
getting clicks uh on these MMA sites
whenever they can use Rogan's name
they're going to use it so that's why it
gets clicked but
um
he had the right train of thought
Fighters hands down are way better than
that today than they were when GSP was
fighting for titles his Evolution yes
Evolution skills and that stuff yeah
yeah 100 and most sports are like that
you know it just is unless they've been
around for a long time but
he's right and this is uh chel sonnen's
reply tail you son of a [__] going for
those clicks I wish I had this I wish I
had this in me I really do I really some
days I'm like oh god oh man if I could
just do like clickbait like TMZ [__]
well you know I'm like uh you know if we
did a headline like jail tears into
Rogan you believe that question mark and
my face like what you know like that
clickbait I just can't do it let's take
a little break because this episode is
brought to you by my friends that better
help that's right getting to know
yourself can be a lifelong process
especially we're always growing and
changing therapy is all about deepening
your self-awareness understanding
because sometimes we don't know what we
want or we react the way we do until we
talk through things better help connect
you with a licensed therapist who can
take you on that journey of
self-discovery from wherever you are
that's right if you've benefited from
therapy in person you can do it online
if you're thinking of starting therapy
and giving better help try it's entirely
online you don't have to go to some
weird office you don't have to sit in
traffic it's entirely done online it's
designed to be convenient flexible
suited to your schedule just fill out a
brief questionnaire get matched with a
licensed therapist you can switch
therapists anytime you want no
additional charge discover your
potential with better help visit
betterhelp.com shop that's better
help.com shop and you save temp shop
your first month better help
this episode of the shop show is brought
to you by on it you knew it was coming
on it baby they've been with me forever
I'm a busy dude that's by Design I have
a lot of my plate I'm always stressed
out but you know who helps me who's
always my champion on it they help me
maintain focus in order to stay in the
zone as long as possible and that's
through Alpha Brain not just any Alpha
Brain but Alpha Brain Black which
promotes attention focus Alpha Brain
helps to support cognitive functions
including Memory Metal speed and focus
you know I need all the help I can get
all right again Alpha Brain can help all
of you out remember names places
addresses focus on complex tasks think
more clearly under stress react more
quickly does that sound good to you cool
man try it out there's no refund
necessary you get your money back you
don't have to send the product back they
keep your money you can share it with a
buddy all right you don't have to return
the product that's how confident they
are in Alpha Brain this sold over a
million bottles the best nootropic on
the planet on it just happens to also
offer the best fitness gear in the world
with kettlebells steel Club bases
sandbags yoga mats you need protein
powders creatine fish oils whatever you
need your Daily Greens they gotcha they
also offer on-demand workouts so if this
sounds like something that could get
your thick ass in shape and help you
better think a little faster why don't
you try it out on it.com shop you see
you receive temperature off the entire
site that's all I got for you audit.com
shop temps off the entire site at audit
you're welcome now let's get back to the
program because I I'll stay really close
to Rogan close with jail like I know
what Jail's doing Jill loves Rogan
absolutely loves them I I would be
willing to bet you too Chael tax Rogan
before he did this so okay man do this
bedroom thing I don't give a [__] like
when jail does those uh
the fighters only Awards I I think it
was like two or three years ago he had
some jokes in there about me he ran them
by me first I know he's known as the
American Gangster and he's gonna hate me
saying this chael's a sweetheart hate to
tell you guys he's not very gangster
maybe back in the day he was but he's
not very gay I mean gangster is a
fighter for sure super dancer but as far
as human beings not Cutthroat great
person great dad great husband like such
a sweet person love jail so jail put
that's not he's so stupid but you get it
I've been at 500 000 views but that's
not a rational statement
um
Joe Rogan's fantastic job when we talk a
lot you get some things wrong dude that
sure very true so a lot of [__] at the
wall and hope some of it sticks uh he
put uh he put Maslow over as an example
that today's wealth rates are far
superior they're better than George
St-Pierre we should just dismiss this
what Joe said and how he did this math
is very common but I would like to
correct you to what a non-420 mind can
come up with me and Joe smokes a lot of
weed game Joe got to the point by saying
that the competition's harder now than
it was then when does that when does the
competition ever have to do with the guy
George is the best that's your answer
ever yeah
uh
then he goes on so Mazda has 16 losses
holds zero UFC records yeah Mazda
compared to George was a bad example
that's true but also okay you know what
kind of uh are you going to put in with
George out there and dominate the
wrestling champion like Josh Koscheck
but yeah he he out wrestled Josh costume
he also used the jab they're doing set
up with a double leg but Josh coscheck
was strictly a wrestler chill that's the
point or knocks out a world champion
like Matt Hughes
really
and would you consider Matt using a
leech Striker jail
it's just me defend Rogue to if we're
going to do this so
chance points are stupid so oh really
well what how are you going to explain
the dominance wrestling Chain by Josh
Koscheck yeah one dimensional Josh
gotchak that's the point dude or uh how
about he knocks out a world champion
like Matt Hughes
yeah he knocked out the wrestler
you know it's like Matt Hughes is a far
cry from a [__] physique my man even
though he's at 55 or some of the guys in
the league today or passes the guard of
legitu Ace like Nick Diaz
yeah yeah
okay uh what kind of equation are you
put into that gap which hundred State
pattern do you believe can take George
Saint Pierre down
100 pounder out there do you believe
George savior cannot take down
let's start with that you cannot uh one
and two by drunk conclusion to others
and if you do it we should dismiss you
and you should tell the kids in the back
seat this that guy is on drugs yeah
that's just chill doing his thing I know
that's just children's thing
um I think cross check did get to a
point where just like some other M.A
Fighters or that were really good at
wrestling they found like striking to me
not at a high level yeah but all those
guys like Okay so let's just go through
chills points Josh koschek compared to
today's 170 pounders at 170 pounds who's
Josh cost my point to chase no I don't
know who's Costa's gonna outstride I
don't agree with this okay and then Matt
Hughes
come on yeah I love Matt Hughes great
for bedtime Matt Hughes now would get
beat by the 50th ranked 120 pounder on
the planet right now it just is what it
is it's not a knocking Matt Hughes Matt
Hughes at his time at the love
competition was one of the best to ever
do it the competition is different now
there's more people doing it there's a
bigger pool it's worldwide it just it's
just a different game now it's not a
knock on these guys just times are
different it's like when you're
how do you think Babe Ruth would do
right now
yeah but he you home run hitter no no I
know thrown against guys with the first
name of Joe and Steve how would he do
against the kid the [__] Latin kid
from the Bronx throwing junk at his fat
ass probably not good
it's just different then Paige Ruth
Falls nothing can do
you think Babe Ruth would do great
against [__] Pedro Martinez
throwing junk out of his ass no he had
another fat white guy throwing the ball
it's just different time you know
it's just different yeah if he compared
it to like you know how like there's a
huge uh debate about
um Jordan and LeBron yes but they've all
achieved this like you know
status of like being the best in the
world yeah
that's why it's a little bit of a weird
thing is a very bad example because he's
been fighting as long as he starts he
said like I think he mentioned all of
them all the all the welterweights on
the top right now would beat I think he
said something like that I don't know
for a fact would be George yeah
um Georgia to George's to Trail's Point
what made George special is because he
was such a gifted athlete you know just
he was so good he written but you look
at just these victories he beat some
very good guys but I think guys like
tomorrow not come around now come on
with beam right now uh Prime Camaro
Colby yes I agree with that Jorge no
Woodley in his prime I don't know dude
or maybe he's just talking about Colby I
don't know he's a weird lit yeah Rogan
has a weird list there because Jorge and
Woodley would probably not beat him
tomorrow after seeing him against Leon
you know and with the bad knees that's a
bad example but if they're both in their
Prime like go to 170 right now
like for instance how do you think
George would do against
Hamza
how do you think he would do how do you
think you do against uh you think you
would just mop the floor with Muhammad
those guys rank three and four
you know
you don't you tell me Gilbert Burns
isn't more round more well-rounded than
a lot of guys that GSB fought
name a guy in the top six that's not
more well-rounded than Matt Hughes or
Josh Koscheck
this isn't a hard debate it's just it's
also
it's not a knock on those old timers
those Hall of Famers it's just that's
what the level they're at they didn't
know any better you know that's it's
where the sport was at it's no different
saying how would Babe Ruth do against a
young kid from the [__] from the
Dominican Republic right now throwing
junk at him probably not [__] good
he doesn't care he was that wasn't that
was it was a different time then you
know
just different
just different man and there's no way to
know no
what else you got all right uh so Paula
Costa remember he had the issues with
the UFC as far as that's why he pulled
out of the Whitaker fight
Brazilian ever so his manager who is
also his I guess fiancee oh interesting
yeah she's the one that made that
statement but apparently he agreed uh
he's he didn't sign the contract but he
agreed financially to the terms of a
four-fight deal and then this is what
his
girl said
Paula went for me one of the most
devalued athletes to one of the most
valued athletes in the UFC I have no
doubt that Paul was the highest paid
Brazilian athlete in the organization
today I don't know if you know any
Brazilian athlete that has paid more
than a million dollars per fight I don't
especially non-title fights no he's
actually getting a milliona fight yeah
and over apparently yeah that's insane
and that's like the minimum that's a
great deal for him I'm surprised USC
gave him that if that's true I don't
know yeah if that's true there's always
you know the UFC never releases this
information
um so it says Paulo agrees to new four
fight deal with the FC but he wants
Strickland and hamzat Strickland's a
good fight for him Hamza is a disaster I
know but it'd be great to watch oh dude
take my [__] money I would love it
because Paul Casa has no quit in him
either so that harms that to be a good
test for Hamza 85 too and for him that
right like you know he was on Air Hawaii
shows a good interview in a great
interview and uh hamzat was they're
asking about
um uh Pierre Pierre right yep yeah
Pierre and uh they said how would you do
he was he just find my career I've
always said that and that's not a knock
on Pierre but he's so one-dimensional
that's where it's all about Styles like
he's a nightmare for Izzy even though as
he did well but it's a tough fight for
Izzy you know but the rest of division
would have a little more
uh I think Alex Pierre would be an
underdog because they have a little more
Tools in their Arsenal you know is he's
not going to shoot for a takedown is
he's not great in Jiu Jitsu these other
guys can get a get away on the feet and
also our nightmare to Grapple with so
it's a little more of a challenge for
Alex Pierre that's all I'm saying Alex
you know gets all up in arms and wants
to challenge me to a bed even though
it's illegal but I would bet you all
[__] day especially if you fight
hamzat I bet my [__] mother-in-law's
house on it I'll tell you that right now
I could use the money man the house is
not cheap you know what I'm saying so if
you want to bet that I'm still available
get your team to reach out to mine
because we can't do it one-on-one right
um but yeah that's right the first
minute is a little intense but it it's a
it's the worst fight possible for Xperia
that's not a knock on Alex Pierre I
don't know who the [__] gonna beat
Hamza
so if that's a knock on the whole
division okay I guess you can all get
upset I'm just saying that's how high
I'm on hamzat I don't know who the
[__] gonna beat this guy also nobody
signed up to fight him he can't get a
fight and now Kobe's like no I asked for
the I asked for the fight they gave me
the fight that's not true
that's not true
otherwise the UFC would have made it
happen yeah it's not true
so he says go back to that for me wait
hold on
but Paulo Hamza is fantastic Apollo
Strickland's a great fight too that
build up would be fantastic that's a
good fight you know that that that's an
even money fight there that's a good
fight
um so let's see he says I told them
uh he went I told him for the
middleweight belt so they've said I only
spoke with Sean Shelby about that fight
Sean Shelby first says yes brother let's
try it then we went back the day after
and said no brother we'll fight uh Kobe
first and then we'll see I said okay
after that we're gonna speak about the
fight with anybody then Alex said I
should fight at 205 or something the UFC
doesn't want uh want to see you and act
fight
um only now and you grow up and fight in
different weight class haven't just won
the middleweight belt oh so he'd fight
for the middleweight belt and then fight
Alex at 205
um they don't see them fight a different
weight class Nobel that's why I've said
from the start
um for 170 he's from 185 we'll fight at
205 it makes sense that's why maybe the
UC didn't call me about that fight I
don't know why they didn't call I was
ready to fight in Brazil it doesn't
matter different weight classes which
weight classes you wanted it's easy to
fight for me in the UFC
um and then you'll ask for clarification
it was in my career first round first
easy no punch nothing yeah yeah
it's a very tough fight for her
alrighty let's go uh this is a quick one
for the fights I mean there's not many
fights coming on this weekend but this
is one of them but Paul so the whole
Jorge miles it all uh gamebred four I
believe it is
uh Paul Daley was supposed to fight on
there and he couldn't fight because he
had Visa issues
it's a great card so far who's Paul
Daley supposed to fight
um Marcus oh Perez yeah from the UFC he
was one of you but the wrestler card is
fantastic it's in Milwaukee it's on UC
Fight Pass pay-per-view yeah your main
event Roy Jones Anthony Pettis I'm
curious about that crazy yeah Jose Aldo
Jeremy Stevens fantastic Vitor jockery
sign me up the Baddie from uh where is
she from Miami sure Pearl Gonzalez
and Gina mazzani who is like a
also UFC was UFC
yeah there's some fun fights on there
definitely the uh the main card or the
top oh stack dude if it starts with one
two three four yeah if it starts with
pearl then you got Vitor jock gray Joe's
Auto Jimmy Stevens yeah Roy Jones and
Lee Pettis take my money stop yeah great
fight
all right so this is uh Cody garbrandt
hinting not necessarily like it's a big
look it's a real thing but hinting that
he might have a dominant Cruz fight
rematch I like this yeah I like this
especially for Dom too I like it for Dom
right because you know you don't want to
see a legend like Dom go out on that
knockout loss head kick to Cheeto so
that maybe can redeem himself against
Cody Cody's falling on hard times even
though he got a win recently but it's a
good fight for it makes sense for both
guys for both guys I dig it same
um here's a quick some batteries this is
a great fight announcement when I saw
this like dude hell yeah
so Ian Gary versus Daniel Rodriguez
d-rod great funny 13th great [__]
fight that's a fight night
it's got to be a fight night has to be
yeah
yeah I love that fight
really really fun fight yeah
I'm big Gary fan
and this is uh this is Dana White at the
press conference for the last fight
and he's discussing Bilal Mohammed and
then also the reporter said something
about Daniel Cormier mentioning Bilal
should be the one right I think most
people in the game think well Muhammad
deserves the title most people know what
the [__] they're talking about do
Daniel Cormier said that the law
Muhammad is the most warranted for a
Welterweight Title shot um nine in a row
right I didn't know what your thoughts
on that was and uh why the law is not
getting a next style shot well Daniel
Cormier doesn't make those decisions uh
it's nice of them but uh yeah uh above
all uh we have plans for below
is going to fight again soon and then
we'll find out who's next in line
yeah so he said he has plans for below
yeah when we know this plan it's a tough
[__] plan it's Chevron right it
should be shafka that's what they want
yeah Jesus
but uh it was just funny how he's like
Daniel Cormier doesn't make those
decisions so I I would run the exact
same way if I like that's why I [__]
with Dana like I'd run the exact same
way I'm like yeah cool it's not his call
yeah yeah there's a there's a million
other people think that what do you want
me to do when you run the UFC run it how
you want to run it but I
I'm going with Colby what else you got
you know like cool there's a million
opinions out there what do you want me
to do
what's this this is just a real quick
one on Patty pimblet he's finished
surgery on his ankle I think he tore his
what's that Achilles I forgot what it
was but he's torn something in his ankle
finally got it done it's fixed but the
of all people he's calling out the same
guy Jared Gordon but he went kind of
hard hard in the paint on it well I
think because Rogan and uh I think DC
were like Kate especially Rogue was like
he lost that fight I don't think
I see why people think he lost that
fight it was close it wasn't a robbery
but you can see why Gordon definitely
could have won the fight 100 I think he
they both need to move on though
yeah but he really wants probably I
think it really and he admitted this
like it hurt him in his heart with Rogan
and DC were like you did not win that
fight
I mean I didn't think you want it I can
see how you want it you know I don't
have an issue with it but I think you
just got to move on he goes I want to
punch his uh his head uh toward the end
of the year I'm gonna run it back I hope
he beats Bobby green that's a very tough
fight for him by the way uh because I'll
snap his arm for him and around had a
box Master with him and still won
because you're [__] hope you watch this
you're a [__] dog [__] am I wore she
couldn't beat me on my best
injured everything go wrong can beat me
on my worst day and I'd beat you on your
best because you're a little bum so he's
going really hard for it
but I mean I'm not excited
just keep climbing dude you don't you
know yeah all right so this is a video
of Morocco you know he needs to he needs
to get a little bit of he needs to take
a page out of suga's book even when
sugar last cheetah like he came out food
truck and everybody like undefeated and
just like all right chill same thing
undefeated never lost Ricky okay yeah
you know it's like it's so so fosterous
for him and he actually won I'm like nah
I'm done with that man I want to go back
and do that [__] you know I beat him
you guys can cry all you want you know
but I guess personally he just wants to
take care of it I mean he must be I
don't want to see but he wants to just
improve everyone yeah so that's that's
cool too but all right so this is Rob
devalashvili uh this is at the San
Antonio event at UFC I don't get why
marab cares like what was the person
saying though but if you're a Rob dude
you you just beat the brakes off this
Russian one of the best bandweights of
all time who do he give a [__] dude I'm
with you on that but I'm also down that
when after this guy this guy apparently
so there's no when you hear the audio it
doesn't sound like he's saying you can't
really tell who he's saying but
apparently he's saying like you should
you should uh fight Al Jermaine Sterling
because that's you know the the actual
fight you should be having you're so
you're kind of running away from that
he's not running away from there yeah
they're homies dumb ass so I'll just
play this for you and listen to the
guide on the camera
I want you to get into octagon with him
in San Antonio
hey right here baby
hey
so he's like whoa whoa right here baby
and then as soon as he gets up
yeah I'd be terrified [__] your face his
exact words I want to [__] your face
whoa dude chill man but I'm glad that
Rob did that yeah I mean I don't know
why he cares like it's a yo man you
fight algebra quit running I'm like
that's such a stupid comment in the
first place
it's funny murad's ready to go yeah
that's the thing man it's like people
don't realize like these you realize
that's a professional cage fighter one
of the best to ever do it and you're
literally three feet away from talking
[__] yeah you know that's that's like
the person that [__] with the great
white or the alligator and they're like
what it bit my arm it's like yeah dude
yeah yeah the [__] you up man and he
acted hard until morale started playing
further yeah I'll climbed that thing
like goddamn spider monkey dude
so I'm glad to see that
uh so okay
uh Tyson Fury and Alexander yusik were
supposed to fight so now it's apparently
off this is what's wrong with boxing and
then so Frank Warren who has I think uh
yeah it's Tyson Fury's manager or
he's on Tyson Fury's side he apparently
leaked this email saying it was uh
music's side and apparently they
couldn't agree to the rematch clause so
they've never fought before but if they
fought and someone won and they had a
rematch you know the the split of the
money yeah you couldn't agree on that so
u16 just kind of just apparently dropped
interesting this is usic's uh management
going gentlemen no this is uh Frank
Warren so Frank Warren but he's shown
the email that u16 sent says gentleman
hope you're uh hope you are all okay I'm
not going into details as well start to
blame or point the finger at anyone but
would like to officially announce that
the team USIC is out of further
negotiations regarding April 29th fight
you guys can put your pencils down we
will speak in the near future
yeah that's a bummer and this I think
this is what Frank Warren said that's
the first I heard and was aware this was
dead and the next day on talk sports
Alex Alexander Jim I want to thank Frank
and Queensbury this is not their fault
they're having their client Tyson Fury
we have our client usek and we're here
to supply demands of our clients Frank
did everything possible to make the
fight happen so someone outside of
Frank's team but yeah so it seems team
walked way over the rematch uh per split
in which they wanted 70 30 in favor of
the winner of the first fight I believe
Furious fight offered 50 50 to USIC if
he was Victorious first time around but
Warren argues that there was never any
time given to negotiate this 70 30 is
insane dude
I mean
definitely a tough matchup for Tyson
he's not a bigger name than Tyson he's
not putting more butts in the seat than
Tyson he's just not
that's what's wrong with boxing that's
boxing doing boxing that's what's wrong
with the sport
and one more boxing thing he said
putting butts in the seats apparently I
didn't realize this but uh Anthony
Joshua was fighting this weekend I had
no idea he's finding someone in uh
Jermaine Franklin and apparently
typically Joshua sells out all the
Arenas that he's in big time right so
apparently this particular Arena I think
it's O2 I'm I forget what but it's
supposed to have 16 000 capacity they
have 1 000 tickets left over and it's
about a week away it's not terrible it's
not bad at all I thought you're gonna
tell me he's only sold one thousand I'm
like Jesus Christ that's right I mean I
had no idea and the guy's fighting you
ever heard of him no that's the thing
you know so it's like this warm-up
tune-up fight for him
so there's they're thinking that uh back
to Fury usig they're thinking fear is
going to fight
um Eddie Ruiz
oh Andy Ruiz Andy Ruiz yeah
I would love that too yeah yeah
or hopefully fights our boy Francis
that'd be yeah well that probably that'd
be the number one thing for sure Francis
and him
even though that was [__] so six six 285
pounds Chinese heavyweight boxer look
how big that dude's legs are yeah he has
calves like Manny Pacquiao but he's six
six two eighty-five Chinese and USIC
doesn't look that much smaller
wait this is Alex Bahia
right yeah
and he's ahead of his fight with the
style Bender sparring this guy who's
freaking like this guy's a legit boxer
too so I looked him up
um he's 24-1 yeah 24-1 Olympic it looks
like he got silver in the Olympics yeah
snake games all this stuff right Big
Bang
so Olympic games you got uh silver in
Beijing
Asian game we got gold
World Championships he got bronze yeah
he's giving me a [__] problem he's
massive yeah so that's who Alex is
sparring with ahead of his stylebender
fight yeah because I bet a giant 66285
Chinese boxers very similar to
Izzy cool to see I'm sure it's gonna
help you down the road Striker really
long really big yeah I guess Jesus
Christ I guess if he can if he can dodge
a wrench he can dodge a ball it's kind
of one of those things you know
Jesus Christ that guy is so big you're
too big
I mean it's all natural uh what else you
got
um
this is another quick one so Dan you
know Dan Hardy his girl Veronica yeah
she looked great original
Veronica Hardy that was she was fighting
in the undercard or the prelims at UFC
286 apparently he was banned from all
the pre you know the fight week
activities other than cornering her so
he's they're saying like how yeah I
don't think Dan Hardy cares I don't know
if you know Stan how he just got a new
gig he's the head of fighter development
something yeah something like that pfl
in Europe so if you look at the card
that he's put on he's put on like legit
European Talent the the uh was it cage
Fury is it Fury what is it the fight big
league out there
uh I mean
cage Wars yeah cage Wars he's putting
all the top talent from there into this
um he's doing it the right way you know
a lot of a lot of those you know when
pfl comes or especially Bellator comes
they use just SPG they use just Conor
McGregor's gym you know that's kind of
you know they've done that so he's
really gonna brought it and use you're
gonna see legit [__] talent I think
it's brilliant brilliant hiring him
brilliant here so this is uh this popped
up recently so I guess I don't know if
this is 100 legit but it's in different
articles in like MMA Mania and like
Daily Mail but so Marvin vittori who's
been on the show before
apparently he's really good friends with
a a rapper in Italy and they were at an
event at the Zone boxing event in Italy
and this is apparently vittori
um not hitting this guy who he's like
camera yeah hits him but so I guess his
buddy is the one that hit this guy like
attacked the guy and the guy's an actual
professional boxer and who did Marvin
knock out the boxer the rapper the boxer
okay so no the rapper the rapper's his
friend okay yeah so the rapper started
the [__] with the boxer and then Marvel
toy apparently did this so that's
probably why the rapper's acting that
tough
apparently Marvel inventory is in the
white
it's about the guy just falls down
you knock him out because the guy's on
the ground kicking
[Music]
see you guys kicking
if does he continue to like beat him
down there no no it's just like a bunch
of stuff that's going on he can't even
tell it's more inventory but then this
picture is where my inventory and his
homie the rapper
they took afterwards I believe and it
says murgatory dangerous but they're
wearing different clothes too so I don't
know how legit the stuff is yeah that's
weird because Marvel was in white yeah
maybe they did an outfit change I don't
know how they're doing Italy yeah it's a
little weird this is one I wanted to
share and that also doesn't look like a
Marvin punch like I was like
like it was very small
syrup in the tank you feel me well the
wrist break
oh my God this raft you've seen this
right yes horrible it gets even crazier
so this ref I'll play the video for you
this is at a uh
Fury FC
yeah Fury fc76 and this is a Friday
before the San Antonio UFC card
[Music]
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
fifteen sixteen Seventeen eighteen
[Music]
oh my gosh
and then he gets his arm broke
[Music]
oh my God
that's awesome
the kid gets choked out and then gets
his arm broke and then comes two
apparently game two yeah
yeah so apparently this referee
they should let's see if I have them
that's him no no
his name is Frank Collazo and he
apparently I don't know the if it's
absolutely true but he apparently uh was
a judge at the next UFC event the San
Antonio event after this this little
crazy thing it's a tough job I get that
but there has got to be some sort of
change man
yeah so apparently according to Daily
Mail he was a judge at the UFC San
Antonio event the day after which is
insane so many so many fighters are
calling for him to be fired and scared
he can't have him working let alone the
low level stuff we can't have him work
the the biggest league in the [__]
world it's just insane man yeah insane
and this I just thought was super funny
this is for you're all fighting and uh
the title says this made me feel weird
makes you feel weird because you're too
gay men
rules
[Applause]
[Music]
the guy like scared on the left
he's all like
but turns out here's a fight with you
guys win
what's up did the the the guy on the
left win the white dude yeah I'll show
you right now well Russian
oh yeah so he oh he did win oh the bad
guy is awful
so the fight was stopped after this yeah
which we can't show but then uh this is
them afterwards they're homies they're
good to go they're good to go yeah that
was weird that whole thing was strange I
know
um all right let's see for those who
watched it's just a like a left hook
clips and behind there and gets knocked
out right away that's it yeah the
biggest thing of the weekend is my boy
Jorge mazdal gamebred boxing got a good
one for you guys it's on fight companion
I'm sorry it's UFC Fight Pass we're not
doing [__] paying for it there's UFC
Fight Pass it's pay-per-view on Fight
Pass I guess is that what they call it
um so you got your main event Roy Jones
Jr versus the legend himself Anthony
Showtime batis Jose Aldo Jeremy steaming
very doorbell for jock Ray Souza Pearl
Gonzalez
it's a fun card man I'll definitely be
watching shout out to Jory for pulling
this off man it's a big deal so shout
out to him all the boys uh doing the
damn thing over there at game bread
boxing man they're doing it so make sure
you check them out if you're in the
Milwaukee area go get tickets you get to
see some of the greatest to ever compete
Combat Sports put it on the line and
that is this Saturday April 1st at 7 p.m
eastern time all right so make sure you
check that out you do have a Bellator as
well my girl cat zangano is fighting
outside that anything else uh just a pfl
doing the damn thing while Mirage is
fighting right my boy Brendan Brennan
yep
yeah Brennan's a badass love his day
and that's pretty much it though that's
it alright kids love you guys uh next
time I'm on tour is I think Atlanta
Atlanta well I'm sorry I just added
April 1st Pasadena shop and friends that
is uh Saturday as well Saturday 8pm show
Ice House Pasadena the new Ice House
shopping friends one show only 8 P.M uh
Atlanta Georgia's April 13th through the
15th so come get you some ATL La Jolla
just got announced Comedy Store La Jolla
is June 2nd through the 4th I'm off to
Europe uh June 15th through I think the
25th and that's Dublin Cardiff London
Manchester Glasgow Belfast
um that's all out there in Europe so
come get you some uh tickets at
thickboy.com or fatkz.com is that it
that's it all right kids love you guys
thanks for watching liking subscribing
um yes thank you love you be nice each
other see ya